[Music]
welcome back so in this example video in
this jupiter notebook i want to walk you
through one of the cautionary tales kind
of one of the pitfalls that you can fall
into when you're doing the SVD the
singular value decomposition and again
this example is from our book
data-driven science and engineering so
you can go download the code and play
around with this yourself but the SVD is
particularly good when your data is
aligned in a way that individual rows
mean the same thing across all of your
columns okay so let's let's talk about
some examples of this so if I'm doing
the eigenfaces example where I have a
bunch of human faces and I'm reshaping
these into X vectors X 1 and X 2 then
this eigenfaces example only really
works when these these faces are kind of
cropped and aligned in the same way
across every face so that if I'm
comparing I'm gonna take the remember
the SVD is based on the inner product or
the core of the correlation matrix or
the inner product matrix of all of these
these images with each other and so when
I'm taking the inner product of these
two images I want to make sure that the
pixel that corresponds to an eye here
corresponds to an eye here so what we
need is for that row to mean the same
thing kind of an apples to apples
comparison across all of the columns if
I have an example where one faces up in
the left corner and one faces down in
the bottom right corner so that you know
nothing lines up then this is gonna be
really a kind of useless decomposition
it's not gonna help us understand the
structure of human faces unless things
are cropped and aligned in the right way
similarly we looked at that ovarian
cancer data sets and in that ovarian
cancer data set we had 216 patients each
of them had 4,000 genetic markers and
this is a great example of data that's
aligned because it was the exact same
4,000 genetic markers across every
single individual person and so in this
case looking at correlations across
these columns in these rows really is an
apples to
apples comparison from patient to
patient okay but if I take a simple
system that I know is low rank and I
just do something simple like rotated or
in this case translate it it destroys
that correlation structure in the data
okay so this is a very simple example to
illustrate how bad things can get you
can play around with it yourself
oftentimes we use the SVD in physical
systems where the columns of X are
measurements of a physical system as
they evolve in time like maybe I have
some traveling wave structure that I'm
measuring in time and even though our
human eyes are really good and our human
brains are good at recognizing patterns
like translational invariants and
rotational invariance the SVD can't
figure that out so it's a big caution
that if you have data that is
translating or rotating the SVD is not
going to give you a good representation
until you kind of factor out that
translation and rotation in the case of
images that means cropping and aligning
okay so here in this two paterno book
we're going to cook up an example that
is a really simple rank one system here
we have this this matrix this is
essentially an image of a matrix of
zeros and ones just white and black and
so you can tell that this is a very very
low rank matrix in fact this matrix
would be the product of this column
times that row okay that's what this
matrix is it's a rank one matrix just as
zeros and ones and if I take the SVD of
this all find that there is exactly one
dominant mode and everything else is
tiny at the machine precision but if I
do something silly like I rotate this
matrix even a little bit so I rotate
this matrix by by 10 degrees now when I
take the SVD of this matrix it's no
longer aligned there's this rotation we
as humans know that there's this
rotational invariance it's still one
object it's a square it's kind of a rank
one object in my mind but I compute the
SVD of this I'm gonna have an explosion
of the rank these singular values are
not going to decay I'm gonna have a lot
of modes I need to keep track of
and so plotting the singular values here
this is the the singular value spectrum
of the properly aligned square that is
in fact ranked 1 and you can see there's
one mode and then a bunch of stuff at
the noise floor this is 10 to the minus
12
but in my rotated matrix spectrum you
see that there is this explosion of rank
I need 250 modes to capture just the
same square but rotated by a few degrees
ok so this just points out the danger of
working your SVD on data that might be
rotating or translating ok so even
though we know about those in variances
the SVD doesn't and it causes a big
problem in this rank explosion so we can
also do this kind of exaggerated case
where we take the square and we rotate
through lots of angles and what we can
see here is that it's a little faint but
you can see it goes from kind of read
through dark blue through light blue and
as you go through those different
progressions of angles you can see this
rank getting worse and worse and worse
and worse you get this explosion of rank
as you rotate this out of alignment ok
to us it's still a rank 1 object but to
the the SVD and Python it doesn't know
about that ok and this is actually one
of the major successes of neural
networks at least is translation
invariance in these convolutional neural
network so that's a good reason people
use these so often because CNN's can
actually handle a lot of this this
translation of objects and pictures
rotations are still pretty tricky other
symmetries are tricky but I just want to
point out this cautionary tale that when
you use the SVD for data that's rotating
or translating you're gonna run it in
trouble ok thank you